hey 42 here have you ever flown into
skle airport in
Amsterdam most Europeans will know it
well since it's the third busiest
airport in the region after London herro
and Paris Charles toore but what you
might not know is that a famous naval
battle once occurred on the very spot
where your plane touched down the Battle
of harir in
[Music]
1573 that's right this entire airport
used to be completely underwater in fact
a substantial portion of this rather
clever country used to be underwater
177% of the land you see on this map
didn't exist 1,000 years
ago so how you may Wonder does a country
simply magic up new land seemingly from
nowhere how do you battle the sea and
win and most remarkably of all how did
the Dutch achieve most of this using
nothing but medieval technology over 800
years ago well by the end of this video
you'll find out some very surprising
truths about this remarkable nation that
has always punched well above its
weights but first I want to ask you a
question who do you think invented ice
skates if you said Canada or Russia
you'd be wrong turns out it was the
Dutch well maybe it might actually have
been the Swiss ice skates dating back to
3,000 BC made from animal bones have
been found in a Swiss
Lake OH the Scottish also have a claim
too since they've been using skates to
navigate their frozen rivers during
winter for almost a millennium but it
can be argued that the Dutch made the
first incarnation of the modern day ice
skate in the 14th century the Dutch
created wooden platforms with iron
blades on the bottom and thus the art of
spinning around like a total Pratt in
public was
born but this dated Dutch design was no
accident ever since people have lived on
this small pocket of land they've been
fighting against the incessant intrusion
of the sea the Netherlands is the lowest
country in Europe it's not part of
What's called the low countries for
nothing 26% of it is below sea level and
therefore the nation has always been
pockmarked with waterways these days a
lot of them are artificial shaped by
centuries of engineering but in the 14th
century they were largely natural and
during winter these waterways would
freeze over so like the crafty Scots the
Dutch created ice skates to navigate
their towns and Fields more
efficiently the Dutch relationship with
the sea has always been a symbiotic one
it has provided thetion with some of the
most fertile land in the world they also
used their familiarity with the sea to
build one of the most formidable navies
in history in the 17th century which
they used to conquer land all over the
map and build the most valuable Trading
Company in history the Dutch East India
Company the Dutch and the Sea may be
watery friends today but it wasn't
always this way because on a dark day in
1219 this friends turned foe a
catastrophic flood swept across the
Netherlands called First St marcelus
flood yeah there was another one it
killed 36,000 people and devastated
entire communities
that's when they knew something had to
change you see the North Sea has always
had a personal Vendetta against the
Netherlands as sea levels have swelled
at various times in the past huge areas
of the country have been flooded it's a
story that just kept on
repeating the Dutch had two options
acques and lets their Homeland rescind
below the depths perhaps retreating to
Higher Ground all 322 MERS of it
or they could go to
war obviously the Dutch being the Dutch
chose the latter but this was a war they
had no right to win you don't just go to
war with the godamn sea and expect to
win except that's exactly what they did
and so beginning in the late 12th and
early 13th centuries the Dutch fought
the sea in their first Skirmish their
initial weapon of choice was the Dyke
communities built huge embankments from
sand and clay around their Villages and
farmlands next they built dams to deal
with smaller sea inlets and Troublesome
Rivers the result of their backbreaking
efforts was nothing short of
revolutionary instead of losing land to
the Sea The Touch started to reclaim
it I've been really trying to keep in
shape after Christmas but work and
stress has made it difficult I know a
lot of you let stress interfere with
your fitness goals or any goals that you
might have for 2024 that's why it's as
important to work on our physical health
as it is on our mental health this video
is in paid partnership with better help
an incredible online therapy platform
that can address exactly this many of us
believe that therapy is only for serious
mental health issues but that's just not
true stress anxiety and low mood can all
Impact our daily lives including our
goals but just hoping these feelings
will go away isn't going to help you it
can actually worsen how you feel in the
future better help offers a practical
and effective approach over 4 million
people have already started Living
happier healthier lives thanks to their
services here's how it works you go to
their site betterhelp.com
sl42 answer a few questions and better
help matches you with a credential
therapist who specialize in the areas
you're struggling with and the best part
they do this in most cases within 48
hours or less you can do it all from
your phone or computer through phone
calls video chats or messaging whichever
way makes you feel most comfortable if
this sounds like something you could
benefit from go to betterhelp.com
sl42 also linked in my description to
get 10% off your first month it's the
easiest way to start talking to a
therapist and get back on track in
2024 as their dikes and dams routed the
waves land that was below sea level
revealed itself once more thus creating
what are known as poers New sections of
land below sea level poers that were
used for farming and even to build new
communities on just think how
incredulous it is that in the 13th
century humans defied the advance of the
sea to uncover new land and build
permanent settlements on
it and once the Dutch had defied the
Deluge of the sea they even weaponized
it for National Defense enter the Dutch
water line a series of water-based
defenses conceived in the 7 17th century
by ingeniously manipulating the water
levels around the country the Dutch
could deliberately inundate sections of
land creating impassible barriers for
enemy troops this was remarkably
effective and used well into the 19th
century safeguarding their Heartland
behind a watery
Shield of course maintaining these dkes
and dams to ensure water didn't slip
through required a huge public effort so
the Dutch created the V shapan local
boards that were in charge of
maintaining dikes dams and waterways the
vter chapen even had the power to Levy
taxes on the local community to pay for
these works the V shapen is one of the
world's oldest Collective Democratic
institutions and it's still in operation
to this day in fact water management is
so entwined with Dutch history and
culture that it forms the basis of their
political system allow me to explain
historically Dutch politics had a
Cooperative philosophy underpinning it
decisions and laws have always been made
by first getting the opinions of
everyone it affects no matter how far
down the social ladder they may be this
ephos even affects company culture
before enacting new policies companies
will consult all the staff even the
person who cleans the toilets there's a
name for this system of values it's
called the poer model it's named so
because when deciding where and how dyes
and wind should be built it has always
been important to consult the local
community and make sure that new
infrastructure won't adversely affect
any particular person or family or their
Farm unfortunately however the poer
model is now falling out of favor in
modern Dutch Society with decisions both
political and corporate being made from
the top down as is typical in
America the dkes were a significant step
forward but occasionally they were
breached the sea was would swell during
storms and flood the poers or heavy
rainfall would fill them up so the Dutch
built windmills more windmills than you
could shake a Stroop waffle at whilst in
most European countries windmills were
used to grind grain in the Netherlands
they were designed to pump water out of
poers lots of it it's hard to overstate
the importance of windmills to the Dutch
by the end of the 19th century somewhere
in the region of 9,000 had been built
across the country and there's still a
common sight to today with over 1,000
surviving examples but come the 20th
century the job of the windmills was
steadily replaced by steam powered pumps
then Diesel and finally
electric by the 20th century the Dutch
had achieved a lot substantially more
than any other Nation before it in the
world of water management but they still
yearned for more more land more
agriculture more tulips more Dutch they
had spent the previous 600 years
fighting local skirmishes with the sea
and their win rate was impressive but
each time they sued for peace the sea
would just Retreat muster its strength
and return with renewed
ferocity so in a final death nail the
Dutch decided to damn harder than they'd
ever damned before they designed a dam
so damning it would Doom the sea to
Eternal damnation you see the Dutch had
always had this really annoying chunk
missing from their
country the zudi was a natural shallow
Inlet bay 30 Mi wide and penetrating 60
mi into the heart of the Netherlands the
zuda has been the sight of a few notable
battles most notably the Dutch defeated
the Spanish here in 1573 at the Battle
of the zuda se but it has also been the
cause of many catastrophic floods over
the
centuries and so in 1927 the
construction of the aslak D began it
would be and still is one of the most
ambitious engineering projects in human
history the goal was to to build a dam
and Causeway stretching 20 miles over
this section of the zuda sea cutting off
a huge wave of water from the Wen sea
and in the process connecting two ends
of the country via a
road after its completion in 1932 the
aslak dke transformed The Saltwater zuda
SE into a new freshwater lake called
Isel for a long time it was the world's
longest Dyke only recently being edged
out by the simong Gum seaw Wall in South
Korea which is one mile longer within
the new Lake iselia incredible things
happened acting as a safe haven for
wildlife certain areas were designated
as natural
reserves and huge new poers were created
such as vingia nuser and others
collectively adding roughly half a
million Acres of fertile land to the
country that was the north under control
at least for the most part but in the
south of the country thing things are
about to go from not great to horrendous
over the span of just 24 hours on
Saturday the 31st of January 1953 a
heavy storm surge caused the North Sea
to flood huge parts of the Netherlands
Belgium and the UK in the Netherlands
1,835 people were killed 70,000 had to
be evacuated and 10,000 buildings were
completely
demolished the British responded by
building the rather impressive T's
barrier but this isn't a video about
Britain over in the Netherlands they
took things one step further they only
completely reconfigured the landscape of
their country in fact they looked at the
entire Coastline of the provinces of
Zealand and South Holland and went so
yeah none of this is any good at all
let's just redo it all from scratch and
so in 1954 the Dutch parliament passed
the Delta law which agreed to build the
country's most ambitious project ever
the Delta Works a series of dams dkes
locks and levies that would completely
change the Dynamics and Landscape of
this substantial area forever making the
residents of Zealand and South Holland
considerably safer in the
process initially the newly established
Delta Works commission wanted the
engineers to construct flood defenses
that would only fail due to a one in
125,000 year weather event but that was
found to be a completely unrealistic
goal so expectations were scaled back a
bit to 1 in 10,000 years which is still
one hell of a flood defense system to
meet this target a purpose-built flood
simulation lab was built since this was
the days before computer modeling if you
wanted to model something you had to
actually build a fcking model so that's
exactly what they did in the middle of a
forest utilizing an existing stream to
simulate the sea they built the V Loop
BOS meaning Forest of the
streams a series of scale dikes dams
sloes and other infrastructure
constructed from
concrete and they planned well because
after the full-size project was complete
Not only was it successful in providing
ample protection to millions of Dutch
the Delta Works was crowned the Seventh
Wonder of the modern world and it's a
deserving title there are quite a few
individual components that comprise
Delta works and each one is perfectly
planned placed and put together but most
notable is the Oster keld or in English
the Eastern Shelt storm surge
barrier it was the most expensive part
of the Delta Works to build and it took
a decade at 5.6 M long it's an
absolutely boric structure and the true
engineering Marvel it contains no fewer
than 62 steel doors each 42 m
wide but I also have to give a special
mention to M caring consisting of two
210 M long Gates that can swing to close
and shut out the
sea it's one of the largest moving
structures on Earth and it protects the
main entrance to Europe's busiest port
Rotterdam the barrier actually uses
computer algorithms written in half a
million lines of code to decide when to
close and when to reopen
and if you travel just 5 miles Inland
for mle caring you'll find another
engineering Marvel that requires a
special
mention this is the Rosenberg wind
wall built along the cand canal this
incredibly busy Port requires huge
container ships to pass through a very
narrow opening in a bridge that raises
up and since the neverland is flat it
can get extremely windy at this
location and that made it very
challenging for huge container ships to
Fred themselves through this very narrow
needle so in typical Dutch fashion they
said screw you wind and built a series
of
125 M tall concrete slabs to stop the
actual
wind they'd already stopped the sea I'm
pretty sure if it was inconveniencing
them the Dutch would find a way to stop
gravity as
well there's no damn doubt that all
these damn dams and damn dkes are for
ever changed a damn Dutch the creation
of poers added huge tracks of arable
land to the country but this wasn't your
normal Farmland these were poers meaning
they were below sea level and that gave
them a huge Advantage their soil
enriched by centuries of aquatic
sediment was incredibly fertile perfect
for agriculture and because of the
extensive system of canals and ditches
irrigation was a breeze literally at the
flip of a switch or the turn of a valve
sufficient water can be supplied
precisely where it's
needed this meant that crops grown on
poer land were not just abundant but
they are also of higher
quality the impact of this reclaimed
land on Dutch agriculture was nothing
short of phenomenal let's take the dairy
industry for instance the Netherlands
though a small country is one of the
world's largest exporters of dairy
products thanks to the Lush nutrient
rich grasses that grow in these
poers the cows here produce some of the
highest yields of milk per animal in the
world the result is the beautifully
creamy howder that is exported
worldwide did you know that howder has
been made in the Netherlands since
1184 making it the world's oldest
category of cheese that is still made
using the same recipe by the way have
you ever seen that floating multi-story
bicycle parking facility in Amsterdam
well what you might not know is that in
Rotterdam there is also a floating dairy
farm that is home to 32
cows and then there's the vegetable
industry the Dutch are masters of
greenhouse farming a technology that
pairs perfectly with the flat Open
Spaces of the poers they've turned their
country into one of the world's largest
exporters of vegetables tomatoes
cucumbers and bell peppers grown here
can be found in almost every supermarket
in almost every country in Europe Europe
and
Beyond but the exports that the Dutch
are best known for can only really be
appreciated from above take a look at
this Drone footage of some French
Farmland now here's a similar shot of
Dutch Farmland just look at those
spectacular colors this country is
absolutely covered in tulip Farms the
Netherlands produces 90% of the world's
tulips throughout the Renaissance the
Netherlands grew well wealthy from the
export of tulips across Europe since
wealthy European Aristocrats viewed
tulips as a sign of wealth and hence
they brought them in great
numbers as demand out strip Supply their
price skyrocketed at one point a single
tulip was worth more than a small house
the whole episode became known as tulip
Mania it is considered by some Economist
to be the first market bubble in modern
history until like all bubbles it
eventually popped in 1637 as the price
of tulips fell off a cliff oh wait there
aren't any cliffs in the Netherlands and
did you know it isn't just tulips that
this country turns out in their
thousands 44% of the world's flowers are
grown in the Netherlands and 77% of all
flower bulbs come from here the
Netherlands is basically the world's
flower shop and it's all thanks to the
mineral Rich poers that the Dutch
created all by themselves the the Dutch
have truly been Pioneers in the field of
water management so much so that today
Dutch Engineers are routinely brought in
to consult on Water Management projects
in almost every other country by turning
what was once to see into some of the
most productive land on Earth the Dutch
didn't just reclaim land they reclaimed
their Destiny shaping their country into
an agricultural Titan respected and
admired the world over
and making the country a ton of
money whilst they're aass it well damn
thanks for
watching just a quick word to say that I
couldn't make these videos without the
support of my patreon members consider
joining the exclusive 42 Discord
Community by supporting me on patreon
it's a great place to discuss my videos
with like-minded individuals and myself
the Link's in the description but if you
don't want to or you can't join my
patreon then please don't worry a simple
like or comment to say thanks would also
put a huge smile on my face thank you